from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between popeyes in the uk and the us
this is food wars
the fountain drinks of popeyes come in
three sizes the small which is 22 ounces
the medium which is 30 ounces
and the large which is
of course
40 ounces
40
ounces
that's so much soda in the uk drinks
only come in two sizes as a kids size or
as a regular size we're not sure how
much is in either of these so we're
going to measure them both
a little over 300
about 450.
but those aren't the biggest i say
actually at the popeyes in the u.s you
can also get a gallon of sweet tea
and unsweetened tea
one whole
gallon
oh look at this
gallon gallon oh and don't you hate when
dummies do that thing where they're like
hey the medium is the sound same size as
the large and it never is it's like
telecon so medium soda large cup
oh wow guys
the medium is about the same size as the
large except for like oh i don't know 10
ounces dump tick tockers you guys don't
even know out of your league tick
tockers i'm the fast food king online
all right
when was this clean last
oh
i'm gonna go 36 what do you think i mean
it could have been the amount the top of
this cup but again you can't
fill this to the brim you have to put a
cap on it and the uk fries just come as
a regular serving u.s we got two popeyes
fries sizes uh regular and large the
regular as we have here just came with
the side of the three piece we got here
and of course a large which is a box of
just fries we're gonna weigh these to
see how they compare to the us
we of course now are going to also weigh
our largest fry
do not sleep on these fries
you'll be surprised to learn that the
inside of the scale is disgusting a
popeye's chicken sandwich in the uk
weighs
exactly 250 grams
in the u.s it weighs
270 grams
in the u.s popeye's signature chicken
comes in seven serving sizes we'll start
with these so of course the one-piece
kids meal then you can upgrade to a
two-piece regular meal which comes with
a side and a biscuit or you get yourself
the three piece and a four piece
side and a biscuit
from there you can get yourself an eight
piece family meal the 12 piece for the
family as well
or just for one person over a weekend
and the largest
the 16 piece are you kidding me
how absurd is this look at all this
chicken
in the uk the signature chicken comes as
a two-piece meal as a three-piece meal
there's a six piece sharer as a nine
piece sharer or a larger size the 12
piece sharer let's weigh a wing a thigh
and a leg to see whose chickens are
bigger
so in the uk our thigh leg and wing
combo came to around 290 grams
here we go first guy up
the leg
next up got that wing
kind of a wimpy looking one and this one
the thigh
how about the attendees in the us we
have these following sizes a kid's meal
has a one piece but what's up they gave
us two
and then from there you get a three
piece which they forgot
and then we have
five piece comes to the side and a
biscuit eight pieces i feel like they're
getting bigger as i go along
look at the size of this tender then we
have the 12 piece i mean guys this is
like a look at this did you know they're
this big this is fantastic i love how
big these are that's what i'm talking
about popeyes thank you and of course
the 16 piece look at this bad boy look
at the size of these guys
tenders in the uk come in four portion
sizes as a piece which is a kid's meal
there's a three piece a five piece
and an eight piece
next up is the nuggets these can be
found in servings of a four piece kids
meal a six piece kids meal eight piece
the 12 piece 24 piece 36 pieces
and then
this double pile right here the biggest
order 48 pieces i have to say does not
look like enough
i know i could destroy that 48 piece
with
confidence
what do we got here oh look at this
sticker this is fun
yeah look at these guys this big one
playing a saxophone how fun is that
that's cool right in the uk we actually
call our nuggets bites and they come in
the following sizes there's a four piece
which is a kids meal a six piece a nine
piece and a twelve piece unfortunately
we couldn't get these today usa we got
biscuits baby
these are the not cookie biscuits that
have come up before in other food wars
episodes these are the biscuits biscuits
and a popeyes you can get them in one
either on its own or probably with just
about every meal you can also get them
in six it's like rolling right down here
and you can also get them in 12.
just overflowing biscuits over here
we actually do have biscuits on a uk
popeye's menu if you order it as a side
you get one biscuit
the biggest single item you can get on
the u.s popeyes menu is this the bigger
family feast it comes with 12 pieces of
chicken
five chicken sandwiches two large size
got the slaw and the mashed potatoes
five biscuits and five apple pies this
entire thing will set you back about 60
bucks and clocks in 10
000 calories if you choose a more
calorific side like the fries i did not
that pretty much dwarfs our largest
single item which is this the 12-piece
shower you get 12 pieces of chicken four
regular sides four biscuits and four
drinks all for the price of 24 pounds
and 95 pence which was around 33 dollars
and 50 cents at the time of recording
we're so bad at fried chicken in the uk
we just don't we don't do it well but
this i gotta say
i feel like a certain kentucky-based
chain has had the monopoly for far too
long and they've let that standard slip
so this is really good i'm thrilled that
the standards are hopefully gonna get
raised and here's everything you can
find in a u.s popeyes you won't find in
the uk and here are most of the things
you'll find on the uk popeyes that you
won't find in the us let's start with
the chicken there are two main exclusive
chicken options in the uk firstly in the
uk we can get a chicken sandwich deluxe
it's just a popeye's chicken sandwich
but there's cheese and lettuce on here
as well
[Music]
what he means to say is they took a
delicious chicken sandwich and added a
bunch of junk
deluxe means vegetables aka
the junk i don't want on my crispy
chicken sandwich popeyes in the uk also
sell hot wings these come in orders of 3
5 8 12 or
20. that might surprise some american
viewers but london in particular has a
pretty big chicken shop culture and
we're pretty passionate about our hot
wings so let's see how these measure up
no no no no no don't get it twisted
we're the wings country
and we should have those i have no idea
why we don't have those
that to me is a very good chicken wing
good level of heat very crispy on the
outside very juicy on the inside what
more can you want we only have one
exclusive chicken item well it's
definitely not an item that's more of a
style of chicken both in the us and the
uk they have the spicy and they have the
regular but we also have something
called the blackened chicken it is a
chicken option without breading
therefore who cares and it comes in the
form of sandwich or tenders here it is
blackened chicken
it's called fried chicken for a reason
this is just like cooked on a grill
grilled chicken of popeyes
what is wrong with you
oh
nope
in both the uk and the us popeye's
chicken sandwiches fried chicken and
chicken tenders are available as either
classic or spicy one interesting fact is
that someone from popeyes told us that
the uk version of the spicy chicken is
actually hotter than it is in america
after they tried it on some focus groups
and they kept asking them to crank up
the heat who said british people can't
handle spices huh
now this is not exclusive because it's
available in both countries however this
is my first time trying an american
style biscuit now the obvious statement
is that to me this just looks like a
scone the color is there the shape is
there the kind of flaky layers are there
even kind of smells like it's gone and
the fact that this is being served with
fried chicken to me and to i think most
british people is really weird
don't get me wrong this is tasty i'm
just still struggling to see any
differences between this and a british
scone
popeyes in the us doesn't just serve
chicken it also has seafood something
you can't find at the uk popeyes now the
u.s popeyes did for a while have a cajun
flounder sandwich which is a fried
flounder filet and a bun with some
pickles and tartar sauce and if the
recording of this is no longer available
i don't know if it was a limited time
thing or they just stopped they're
taking a break i don't know but you can
still get the popcorn shrimp this is it
and it comes in
a quarter pound serving
there are no seafood options in the uk
but we do have one vegan option which
you guys don't have in the us and that's
the creole red bean sandwich this is a
100 plant-based red bean patty with some
tomato some lettuce and a creole sauce
but unfortunately we weren't able to get
one today i will say the popeye's menu
in the us doesn't look very vegetarian
friendly so maybe if this takes off in
the uk you guys can get it too whatever
the hell that thing is a hundred percent
plant based red bean pet
that will never touch american shores
that can stay in the uk
no one's going to pop eyes for
vegetarian vegan anything it's a fried
chicken place so no now we have two
sides of exclusive to us red beans and
rice oh so we got a
bad boy a thingy thing did they not give
us any
silverware mystery spoon from somewhere
in the office all right
red beans and rice there it is
and
coleslaw
we just have the one exclusive side in
the uk and it's onion rings these are
battered using buttermilk similarly to
the chicken unfortunately we weren't
able to get these today either i got a
bunch of sauces in front of me and you
know what that means it's sauce talk
we've got
a tartar sauce
the creole
cocktail sauce
creole is a type of cuisine in louisiana
blackened ranch was this supposed to be
for the black and chicken do you think
and of course we have regular buttermilk
ranch
well we already know what ranch is
ranchy
blackened ranch
oh that's way better
the sweet heat had this earlier with the
tenders can confirm fantastic sauce wild
honey mustard
and the
bayou buffalo sauce
in the uk we have the following
exclusive sauces
we have this voodoo sweet chili sauce
which could be quite similar to the u.s
sweet heat source
then we have a garlic mayo
as well as a mango habanero sauce which
sounds really good it's not exclusive
but shout out to the mardi gras mustard
because this stuff slaps
now it's not exactly an exclusive but
it's worth a shout out musician megan
the stallion recently launched a collab
with popeyes and released the hottie
sauce you can get as a side for dip or
pre-edit your chicken sandwich or if
you're in the uk you can dip a hot wing
into the hottie sauce and have a hot
wing summer
she's also becoming a popeye's
franchisee as she is opening her own
popeyes soon and then underneath this it
says need some wap content here open to
ideas i'm assuming she's the one who did
the song wap i don't know who this
person is i've never heard wap i just
know it as a reference on the internets
and i am going to bask
in the glory that only some of my age
can of not having any idea what a
popular thing is
ah
desserts
this is a
cinnamon apple pie
what's up oh my god
what
and
chocolate chip cookies did she was she
with paul davis pete davidson for a
while was that the one no that's
arianna's lamb we have an exclusive
dessert option of our own which is ice
cream sundaes now these are available in
the following flavors
vanilla
chocolate
caramel with oreos or with lotus biscoff
you can also pay an extra 50p to add
little pieces of oreo or biscuit off to
any of these sundaes if you've watched
food wars for long enough you'll know
that i really don't like biscoff and i
know that's a very controversial opinion
so don't send it for me please
all right so before you sell those big
gallons of tea there was sweet tea and
unsweetened tea very nice we also have a
premium lemonade that's this right here
been sipping on because this chicken's
getting to me
they also have a premium strawberry
lemonade and they also have this right
here
hawaiian punch
you guys don't know hawaiian punch is it
is
fruit punch
oh yeah the good stuff's at the bottom
and ginger ale oh i have a headache all
of a sudden we have a range of exclusive
drinks in the uk some of which are hot
and some of which are cold we'll start
with the hot drinks it wouldn't be a
british fast food menu unless you get a
cup of tea then we have a range of hot
coffees including a cappuccino an
americano a flat white and a latte then
we're on to the cold drinks including
some bottled options like this oasis
summer fruits this sparkling water and
this orange capri sun of all the
linguistic differences between the
states and the uk this might be the one
that annoys me the most we pronounce
this capri sun you pronounce it capri
sun you're putting the emphasis on the
completely wrong part of the word get it
right in the uk you can also get a range
of hand spun milkshakes which
unfortunately we couldn't get today when
they are available you can get them in
similar flavours to the sundaes they
come as biscoff oreo vanilla chocolate
caramel or also strawberry and just like
the sundaes you can pay an additional
50p for an additional biscoff or oreo
topping
a chicken sandwich from a uk popeyes
contains the following
if you get the chicken sandwich at a u.s
popeyes it contains this
what if you made it a meal if you add
the regular serving of popeye's cajun
fries you'll be adding the following
a side of fries in the uk contains the
following
poof
add this medium coke to the mix and
you're adding 368 calories 99 carbs all
of those are sugar and 88 milligrams of
sodium
and a regular coke in the uk adds 180
calories zero grams of fat or saturated
fat 45.6 grams of carbs all of which are
sugars and zero sodium and what is the
total of this us meal
1335 calories 56 grams of total fat
19 of those grams are saturated fat 182
grams of carbs
106.5 of those grams of sugar and 2
118 milligrams of sodium
yo
the uk total 1 300 calories 63.7 grams
of fat of which 20.4 grams are saturated
135.4 grams of carbs of which 54.8 grams
are sugars and 1160 milligrams of sodium
now obviously the sugar stats here look
bad but in popeye's defense a majority
of the sugar is coming from this 30
ounces 30 ounces of coca-cola now if
you've got a sugar-free soda instead it
would be a much lower figure the meal
does contain however 95 of your daily
saturated fat as well as 92
of your daily sodium perhaps
surprisingly it seems as if the fat and
saturated fat totals are actually higher
in the uk than they are in the us this
meal would take you just over 100 of
your daily saturated fat allowance
however the sodium content is way higher
here than it is in the uk the biggest
difference comes in the chicken sandwich
this guy right here for some reason has
260 percent more sodium than that in the
uk
unfortunately popeyes does not disclose
a full ingredients list in the u.s only
allergens it's a similar deal in the uk
popeyes doesn't disclose a full
ingredients list just allergens the only
sort of surprising thing we found out in
the us is that there is fish present in
the beans and rice
but what else do we know about the
popeye's food
well for one on the website there is a
list of slightly vague commitments to
removing all artificial colors flavors
and preservatives from the fried chicken
by the end of 2022. so that's this year
guys better get on it also by the end of
this year they want to remove all msg
from their chicken now correct from them
wrong that implies they currently are
using msg on the chicken but how much
and the wood chicken dishes they're
actually adding msg they have not
specified they also want to use only
cage-free eggs by the end of 2025.
take your time there guys jeez
also cage-free eggs what about the
chickens
one interesting thing is that in the uk
popeyes has pledged to make all its
chicken halal meaning it's suitable for
muslim people to eat popeye's uk also
uses red tractor assured chicken this is
a farming standards board which oversees
poultry farming in the uk to be red
tractor assured you can't do things like
wash your chicken in chlorine or use
antibiotics on your chicken unless it's
approved by a vet to treat a specific
illness rejector doesn't exist in the
u.s but popeyes does say it uses chicken
free from added hormones and steroids
there's a commitment on popeye's website
to removing antibiotics from its
chickens by the end of 2021 so that's
right around the corner of the time of
recording this and we reached out to
them for what was going on and they told
us axe
let's just go for it and nothing
red tractor certification also means
that chickens must be kept in a safe
comfortable hygienic and sufficiently
sized housing given a full healthy diet
and have permanent access to
environmental enrichment that is
suitable for their needs again we do not
have red tractor in the us but popeyes
claims it wants to quote promote
practices that support and address the
globally recognized five freedoms of
animal welfare end quote these
principles brought the line up with the
red tractor guarantees which are freedom
from hunger and thirst
freedom from discomfort freedom from
pain injury and disease freedom to
express normal natural behaviors like
accommodating for chickens instinct to
roost and freedom from fear and distress
i don't even get those freedoms
i'm terrified all the time
so it looks like they're aiming for
equivalent standards even if they don't
have a nice red tractor badge or
whatever to prove that they've achieved
now obviously popeyes is a louisiana
fast food chain joe asked me to try and
find louisiana on a map i don't know
much about american geography i can tell
you where california is
where texas is where florida is
new york is somewhere over here i think
um
if i had to hazard a guess as to where
louisiana was
i mean it's the south right it's the
south
maybe
is it is it like this one
maybe that maybe that one there
was in the south this food was in this
house
was in this house there's food wars in
the south